David is on the line san antonio hi
David how are you I'm good thank you
good how can I help so I'm just getting
frustrated I'm getting started my wife
and I don't see eye to eye on finances
ever and I've she's always done the
finances I've never said anything to her
about it and you know now that I'm you
know figuring out how much we have in
debt and we have 100,000 in debt yeah
that's not including 170 thousand dollar
home and she thinks a budget silly she
thinks of snowballs silly so I mean it's
just almost impossible to get started I
have money in an emergency fund you know
I try to pay haste up off and I know
it's just so difficult getting started
okay
well I'm confused as to why she thinks
those that the idea of being out of debt
or the idea of having a plan is silly
that's both college-educated and I don't
know she is I've always let her pay the
bill she's handled the money and you're
$100,000 in debt that sounds more silly
than having a but that's what I said you
know so then but it comes off as a no
this is a personal attack on how I'm
doing stuff which it's not you know hey
we need to get out of this yeah yeah and
uh yeah I think probably the first thing
is is that you owe her an apology for
all the years of you not helping her
with this subject and leaving it on her
to make the decisions by herself and
then just couch it and this is not a
personal attack but I'm just very
interested in helping now and I want us
to work together and you know if you
guys can't work together on your life
goals you don't have a financial problem
you have a marriage problem but it could
just be your approach is lousy that
you're you know you're being a bull in a
china shop and you may just need to sit
down and
you know Todd started talking about I
really am so excited about where we
would be if we didn't have any debt and
the only way I know how to get out of
debt is to have a plan to get out of
that what do you think you think we
ought to stay in debt you think this
hundred thousand is working for us I
mean you know and just start talking to
her like that and instead of start
throwing what we're gonna do what we're
going to do what we're going to do let's
talk about why we're doing stuff and why
you're excited about it and you know is
that not make sense to you and then back
into the what but a lot of times guys in
particular we start with the what and
not the why and that's the thing so um
you know do that and and maybe go
through Financial Peace University
together and that might be a way to do
it so I'm check-in you know hold on and
I'll have Kelly pick up and we'll give
you a Financial Peace University
membership and I'll give it to you if
you can't get her to go but if you can
get her to cuz you don't want to go out
or it'll cause a divorce because cause
it to be worse because you'll get more
excited and she'll be less excited but
if you can get her to go to the group
with you I will give you the program
it's called Financial Peace University
and only nine weeks you go once a week
for nine weeks to the group and then
you've got a year access to every dollar
and every dollar plus and you know
that's what you do there so hold on I'll
have Kelly picked it up and maybe if you
can get her to do that that might might
be a way to get you guys on the same
page and maybe she could start to
understand why you're excited about this
not just what you're trying to do there
is a difference so hey thank you for the
call man hold on Kelly I'll pick up
[Music]